flags across Florida are at half-staff
to honor five people killed in a mass
shooting at a bank and we're learning
more about the victims all of whom were
women they include one customer and four
employees of the SunTrust Bank in
Sebring 21-year old
Zef and saver was charged yesterday with
five counts of premeditated murder
police are searching for a motive
DeMarco Morgan has details of the
victims and it was a wife to my brother
a mother to seven children a daughter a
sister and family to everyone she knew
our opinion Williams had only been
working at SunTrust for three weeks when
she was senselessly killed Wednesday Tim
Williams is her brother-in-law
her life was truly a light in this world
she made it a better place
SunTrust employees Marisol Lopez and
Jessica Montague were also killed as
well as customers Cynthia Lee Watson her
best friend
Marilyn Martin says Watson married the
love of her life two weeks ago police
say Stefan saver armed with a
bulletproof vest and a nine-millimeter
handgun killed his victims while he lay
facedown on the ground he now faces five
counts of premeditated murder he
recently moved to Florida from Indiana
where he met Alex gorlag Gerlich says
she was Avery's ex-girlfriend last week
she says he sent her a picture of a gun
he just for some reason always dated
people and wanted everybody to die
I've been scared for years and every
single person I've told is not taken
seriously
Victor sparks says he tried to enter the
bank Wednesday but it was locked
through the window he saw a man pacing
with five women on the ground before
hearing two loud bangs as I was probably
the last person other than the shooter
to see them alive that really hits home
for CBS this morning DeMarco Morgan
Sebring Florida awful story people just
living their lives dying for no reason a
three year old boy missing for two days
in Eastern North Carolina is alive and
he's recovering in the hospital this
morning
rescuers found Casey Hathaway last night
in the woods near where he disappeared
the toddler was wet Cole
and calling out for his mom he suffered
only minor cuts and bruises Hathaway was
playing in his grandmother's backyard
when he apparently just wandered off on
Tuesday police say there is no evidence
of an abduction here